let's continue we've got 22 people
holding right now let's go to the person
who's been holding the longest of those
that are that are still with us here
we'll go to our caller from the 208 area
code caller what's your name where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today ah hey David uh my name's
Terry by the way uh anyways so I have an
issue with how how it is we're going to
get our education system under wraps and
what I mean is I listen to this like
this is a kind of a little bit of a
thing that it makes sense but back in
the old days black people or African
Americans and most minorities yeah in a
way their districts were redlined all
right so they didn't have the ability to
you know get the taxes for school and
everything else that you know comes with
great housing and stuff like that so
it's like essentially starting a class
of people that when they were freed like
like from the from the one from the one
yard line on upon yard dash opposed to a
around a 75 yard line and as it happens
but you see all of this all of what's
happening out there and you see all of
violence in all of the all of what is
the ghettos in this in this country and
it's just been a progressive digression
of you know of human of you of the way
these humans are ya and I feel like the
only way to combat it is to you know
influence these kids that they're there
are other things out there than you know
there you know in terms of opportunities
but they're not getting the same kind of
opportunities within the inner spin or
urban area yeah and so you're getting it
a lot of in order here you're going to
get a lot of issues that are really
important one is you have a lot of
people yeah typically people who are
against any form of affirmative
section who say listen if you look at
the laws on paper now there's no
discrimination based on race okay and
that gets to a couple different issues
one you pointed out with your steps are
you starting at the 75 yard liner at the
one yard line there's another example
which is the Monopoly game example which
is if four people start playing Monopoly
and they play for two hours and then a
fifth player jumps in you can say listen
on paper everybody's playing by the same
rules the fifth player starts with the
exact same amount of money as the other
players they're rolling the same two
dice but all the properties on the board
have been purchased many of them have
houses or hotels so that rent is really
expensive that is a very good way of
understanding how the idea that hey we
fix discrimination in the US it's not a
really good explanation or response or
defense of what's going on but there's
another issue that that you're dealing
with as well which is the having
equality of potential is not the same as
having equality of opportunity and many
individuals like to say if you're a
smart kid you are just as likely to
succeed if you're born and live your
entire childhood in a poor neighborhood
as you are if you're born to a middle
class or wealthy family because it's
about the potential of the kids the kids
may well have the same potential but if
the environment doesn't provide them
with the same opportunity they're going
to be at a disadvantage so you're
touching on a lot of really important
issues it's a more complicated issue
that I can solve here but I'm glad
you're thinking about it yeah thanks oh
thanks yeah it definitely it's just it
comes to mind because I'm
african-american and you know I actually
moved out of the ghetto from Chicago
when I was young and I can see that the
differences as to you know where I am in
a you know predominantly white area to
opposed to you know the rigors of living
in a hard city where you know
opportunities aren't there and I'm not
right not to be super clear about this
at you're not saying that it's because
you're around white people it sounds
like you're saying it's because
the house structurally different the
neighborhood you're now in is right
absolutely absolutely you can see the
differences between the two if you were
to step outside and experience both of
them and and a lot of not a lot of
people will understand like what happens
what happens in the in the urban area as
opposed to what happens in suburban
areas are just come to complete
different worlds and it means it's not
it's not due to its not it mean if dude
it definitely schooling and you know and
none of my family's graduate or anything
like that so it's just all predicated on
that you know how how your counselors go
about handling your situation how you
how you're urged more in these areas of
suburban areas you that there that you
know there is a light at the end of the
tunnel aside from you know selling drugs
or you know doing everything else like
that but the mindset in the hood is that
yeah it's hard for the tarp or suburban
people to understand what they go
through and it's hard for you know the
other way around as well so listen
thanks some are very important tactic
I'm glad I waited if you've got an
uphill battle with secretary DeVos as
far as education goes that's for sure
alright thanks so much for the call
hopes to hear from you again and on that
note let's take a break please join us
on reddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t any of these topics if they're
interesting by all means discuss this
with us on our reddit discussion forum
or calls after the break